les détaillants qui vendent leurs
produits en ligne ont un problème de
plus en plus important les retours les
consommateurs retourne entre 15 et 30%
des produits achetés en ligne
la valeur des marchandises achetées en
novembre et en décembre est retournée
par la suite ça devrait dépasser les 41
milliards de dollars aux états unis
ces objets sont vendus revendu souvent
arabe est donnée ou tout simplement
détruits et d'ailleurs la destruction de
ces marchandises neuves achetées puis
retournez en ligne ce problème majeur
conséquences économiques conséquences
environnementales
on va en parler avec marc tassé il est
professeur à l'école de gestion telfer
de l'université d'ottawa spécialisé dans
les tic dans la gouvernance d'entreprise
merci d'être là monsieur passé on va
faire nos devoirs le point sur cette
tendance le retour de marchandise à
prendre l'ampleur ces phénomènes là oui
malheureusement c'est quelque chose
qu'on voit de plus en plus on s'est
rendu compte que ça demandait de 95 % au
cours des cinq dernières années donc ça
doublé est carrément oui donc c'est une
évolution qui est en parallèle
évidemment au commerce en ligne
il semble qu'on retourne plus d'achats
en ligne d'articles qu'on a acheté en
magasin
c'est une tendance qu'on observe de plus
en plus ah oui effectivement je pense ou
des raisons majeures c'est lorsqu'on
achète en ligne
on est un peu dans l'anonymat donc de
retourner trois études que j'ai acheté
c'est beaucoup plus facile que si
j'allais retourner en magasin et de se
confronter un peu de questions la
question à oui parce que il y aurait une
douzaine à le faire c'est ce que vous
laissez entendre oui c'est ce que les
études ont démontré que les gens ont
vont être un petit peu plus gêné s'ils
doivent se déplacer en magasin alors
qu'en ligne
tout se fait sous le couvert de
l'anonymat ça semble assez clair que des
lâches
il ya une intention de retourner des
articles et le cefrio qui laisse
entendre récemment avec des études que
l'étiquette de retour qui est payé
fourni à la livraison d'un produit c'est
important pour au moins les deux tiers
de ce qu'ils achètent en ligne donc dès
qu'on commande
on a l'intention de retourner la
marchandise effectivement sur deux
domaines du vêtement des fois les gens
sont pas certains de la grandeur sont
pas certains de la couleur donc ils vont
en acheter trois ou quatre arrêts
au-delà de cette grandeur et par la
suite on se disait bien je prends celui
qui me convient pelé baisse mais je vais
y retourner parce que ça fait partie de
la politique de retour avec un énorme
impact évidemment environnementales ont
sans doute tous ces colis qui font des
allers retours si vous voulez mais pas
que pour les détaillants aussi faut il
penser ça devient compliqué en termes de
gestion des stocks
qu'est-ce que ça comme un pacte pour les
entreprises ce qu'elle a vu comme tel il
faut qu'ils aient comme tel l'endroit
pour pouvoir les garder
premièrement il faut avoir de
l'entreposage avoue avoir des employés
qui vont pouvoir les inspecter qui vont
pouvoir par la suite d'une fausse sont
inspectés de revoir ce qui doit être
conservé ce qui doit disposer et par la
suite d'un dorée emballé et ce jeu vous
érable semaines certaines entreprises
ont fait le calcul et sont rendus compte
que c'était plus avantageux pour eux de
tout simplement le détruire l'ex
comptable c'est purement logique
financière et on parle de marchandises
comme quoi la caisse qui peut être j'ai
pris un peu n'importe quoi
habituellement ce sont des vêtements
parce que les vêtements le fait de les
nettoyer de l'airé emballé ça serait
trop dispendieux versus qu'est-ce qu'il
va les besoins les problèmes donc c'est
la marge de profit qui est faite sur ces
produits là qui est très mince c'est ça
qui pèse dans la balance
exactement hondros mais comme je disais
tantôt on fait uniquement une analyse
qui est très financière et comptable on
le regarde pas comme tel le coût
environnemental
on le garde pour la responsabilité
environnementale de l'entreprise est-ce
que c'est légal de faire cette que les
entreprises ont le droit de faire ça et
soukaina dowie en europe en france et
des lois ont changé en allemagne soit
après changer les lois aussi où ce que
des gens vont devoir démonter les
entreprises vont devoir démontrer
quelques avec les retours que les soit
qu'ils utilisent dans un marché
secondaire ou tout simplement qu'elle
les donne à des oeuvres de charité
ok si c'est légal de le faire au canada
c'est certainement pas un comportement
d'affaires jugés responsables comment on
définit l'aspect éthique de cette
problématique là qu'est ce qu'on dit à
l'entreprise une responsabilité sociale
corporative de polluer c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas bien et elle doit
faire en sorte où sont aussi que des
gens qui sont dans le besoin qui ont
peut-être pour les moyens de s'acheter
certains vêtements donc c'est ce que
peut-être mieux comme tel de l'évent
dette
mais de faire en sorte que ce soit
disponible plutôt que ce soit simplement
incinérés ou enfouis un site
d'enfouissement
clairement ça doit être mauvais pour
l'image de marque en saas et ça fait
scandale je prends l'exemple lâché m
lorsqu on avait appris que l'entreprise
brûler des invendus évidemment
l'entreprise avait été vertement
critiquée alors si c'est connu est-ce
que ça nuit à l'image et même aux
affaires d'une entreprise qui fait ça au
total mais ça l'a fait le risque
réputationnel de l'entreprise où ce que
les gens n'ont pas une telle perception
comme vous y tente ou hlm
on a eu aussi la compagnie burberry qui
effectivement faisait la même chose les
préférer les jetez plutôt que lire en
arabe et la problématique c'est que les
consommateurs se sont un peu les volts
et ont boycotté dû simplement ils ont
changé leur politique même amazon
si vous retournez des produits
électroniques ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'ils prennent une boîte de dieu pied
par deux pieds ils vont la rendre les
complètement et par la suite devant la
vente pour 200 dollars
en vous garantissant que vous avez une
valeur d'environ 550 dollars au moins
c'est une usage dérivés qui est mieux
que simplement de jeter
bon oui effectivement là peut-être qu'on
avance un peu mais amazon
on a déjà reproché à l'entreprise quand
même de jeter de la marchandise au
canada ces cas ou pas il semblait c'est
la même chose les pressions et genève a
besoin
malheureusement effectivement l'histoire
monsieur passé c'est que le commerce en
ligne c'est là pour rester est ce que le
consommateur est en conscient de ça est
ce que c'est à lui de changer son
comportement
jusqu'à un certain point je pense que
oui lorsqu'on achète comme tel c'est
peut-être se dire bien que j'accepte est
restée en deux grandes a plutôt que dis
je montre aux quatre grandes ap
je pense que tu sais que tu sois de
sports extra large du port du village ne
pense qu'à pantin extra larges
vainqueurs médium non plus je pense
qu'il ya une certaine conscientisation
que les gens doivent avoir
et deuxièmement aussi c'est peut-être
d'en parler et de faire en sorte de
mettre des pressions sur les pouvoirs
politiques pour faire en sorte que ce
soit un choix de société de ne plus
tolérer ce genre de comportement mais
les entreprises ont quand même je pense
que oui et pour eux aussi c'est de
réaliser que de plus en plus les jeunes
consommateurs ont tendance à battre au
critère important pour hull le respect
de l'environnement
1 le respect de la société fait part de
l'entreprise ainsi que la bonne
gouvernance
en espérant que ça change merci beaucoup
pour vos explications mais ses passes
merci beaucoup bonsoir